350 vis cruciformes voilà ce que je vous
ai commandé et vous en avez livré trois
ans 29
évidemment je les ai comptés avec ce mec
sa mixtape hutin on va dire que c'est la
chambre de mes paroles je suis car tout
ça existait bien 810 en effet nous
revoir et merci
[Musique]
avec ses galeries ses albums dans le
logo google je ne parle pas votre langue
au lieu d'inventer des proches à coup
les pitchouns ayant mais comme une tâche
urgente dans votre langue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
1 milliard à milliard d'indiens cas pas
une personne ici qui va s'occuper à
aider votre ami qui s'appelle agite
rider il est venu voir ici son oncle je
vous le laisse ce n'est pas possible
c'est impossible mais je les ai amenés
jusqu'ici à temps vous le gard et il
faut dire combien de temps va durer ce
site on ne vient pas tout
quand on veut c'est sacré on y va ah bah
non il est en train de dessiner
on se lève toro se couche
la seule chose que tu sais dire c'est
non alors ça non tu sais le dire au
lavage thé conduit
c'est comme ça qu'il a eu de la chance a
dit tu es tombé sur toi
j'aurais aimé avoir sa chance et
pourtant je parle le français mais
[Musique]